a sad announcement from legendary singer  tony bennett today  his wife says that he is now battling  alzheimer's disease  the 18-time grammy award winner and las  vegas headliner started his career back  in the 1940s  his family kept the diagnosis a secret  for more than four years but they  finally revealed it in an article for  aarp magazine  bennett's wife spoke with gail king on  cbs this morning  he's not in any pain and that's why he  doesn't think anything's wrong with him  he's like susan nothing hurts i feel  great you know he works out  five times a week he sings twice a week  with a pianist that comes over he only  understands  if something is an ouch you know then  there's a problem if you ask him how he  feels he's i feel great  is there anything wrong tone nope  nothing's wrong  bennett's wife you just heard from there  susan she says his greatest therapy is  singing he's recorded a series of mini  concerts from his home and he still  remembers  every word beautiful voice